when that alarm clock goes off monday
morning and kids rise and shine to head
back to school well they want to be
dressed in something new and fresh and
trendy i checked out macy's at fashion
show las vegas to find their newest
looks for this school year where kids
can own their style
colleen liard store manager is with us
to tell us what's hot and the trends for
back to school good morning colleen good
morning you've got some great fashions
here too what are kids wanting to wear
back to the classroom well let me tell
you about this so first of all as you
can see denim is hot hot hot hotter than
it's ever been and yes guys the 80s are
back so if any of you remember wearing
these cute little overalls overalls are
it you've got lots of denim layer up to
happen you've got tie-dye over here it's
so cute and the girls love this i see
flannel now this will come when it's
come in play when it's cooler right not
right now i have to tell you the girls
still wear flannel no matter what the
temperature is they're still going to
wear flannel because remember it still
gets a little chillier at night time but
the layered look is really really
popular so you put a little cute little
graphic tee your flannel layer it up
with your denim and you're good to go
okay 80s style denim flannel we got it
yeah what else is going on let me show
you the ones too
they do so really really important is
you're all inclusive activewear guys so
activewear is also still very very hot
super cute to wear but let's talk about
this this is a brand that seems to have
had a resurgence champion yes so
champion really years ago champion you
did a lot of basics right now they're
great with fashion they really
just i would say reinvented the brand
you've got a lot of great fashion here a
lot of great value comes in this brand
and super cute for the kids and it's
just adorable look at the colors i know
how well the girl would not like these
colors and most everything usually comes
with that third layering piece for mom
to have put on okay when you're in the
cold air conditioning when you're in the
cold air conditioning if you're lucky
that your school has air conditioning
all right what else what for the little
ones the younger ones so we've got these
cute little um tommy hilfiger outfits
here for the cute little ones as well
and then you've got this look at this
who doesn't need this cute for picture
day because picture day
usually comes up towards the end of the
month got a cute little ralph lauren
outfit for her as well these are
affordable designers these are
affordable designers these have great
value you know anytime that they're on
sale usually 30 to 50 percent off we can
get you in a tommy hilfiger or a polo at
any given time and what about the older
kids back here let's get this
about this what is this i love it so
this is artwork so a lot of artwork is
really popular right now that we're
embedding into either denim or
sweatshirts or so on and so forth like
that and then when you take a look at
this too so it's artwork and patchwork
which are the latest trends
yeah so you can see that the embroidery
look how cute that embroidery is that's
adorable so again like if you think
about the 70s inspiration the 80s
inspiration what's old is new right
where's the grunge is the grunge gone so
no it's called what modern day grunge
i don't i don't think grunge will ever
be gone you still got the ripped denim
you still got all of that stuff going on
the extra layers and all of that kind of
stuff for the older kids
but it's still very popular okay grunge
and you say graphic tees yeah you know i
think it's just about owning your style
and who you are and these are great
add-ons too so if you've got a very busy
mom and they don't really know what the
kids are gonna wear you know what grab a
bunch of tees one for every day of the
week
and you've got a cute little outfit you
layer it up with your your denim your
denim skirts your skorts whatever you
need and you're good to go and you look
super fashionable they are really cute
and super affordable
super affordable that's what we want so
check it out colleen says most of the
styles that we saw there at fashion show
las vegas can also be found in the
neighborhood macy's stores too henderson
summerlin and they're always always
having a sale including this weekend